this is the fastest declining mammal in
the UK
the water vole wants a common animal
scurrying along ditches rivers and
streams have been in decline for over 50
years it's believed that 94 percent of
this species has disappeared from the UK
but as this animal is on the brink of
extinction conservationists have been
purposely breeding more water vaults to
reintroduce them to our ecosystem we can
produce about 3000 water balls a year if
our whole captive breeding facilities
used and we provide you water voles for
reintroduction projects from the
Scottish border fight actually from the
Highland line right that we don't to the
south of England and we know that those
animals can actually cover and breed and
do rather well in 2014
water voles disappeared from the Hogs
Mill River in southwest London after
years of decline but in just under 12
months the much-loved mammals could be
back in these waters and it's thanks to
the local community volunteering to make
a change we've trained 60 volunteers
taught them to see the world for a water
voles eyes so they can walk up and down
this river and they can look at the
different types of habitats they can
work out a good habitat or bad habitat
and hopefully in the next year or so we
can start considering where we can
release populations of waterfowl back to
the river we're all very passionate
about this it's led by a very passionate
group of people and it feels like it
could be a great success but the UK's
wildlife continues to decline according
to the results of the latest state of
nature report almost half of UK species
have fallen since 1970 such as grayling
butterflies and greater mouse aid bats
both teetering on the edge of extinction
the report also revealed more than two
thousand species are at risk of
disappearing altogether in the future
the causes for decline of the uk's
wildlife is down to a number of reasons
evidence from the past 50 years shows
climate change pollution and the way we
manage our land for farming are key
factors but whilst the data is alarming
conservation initiatives like this one
are cause for some cautious hope over
the past 10 years government spending on
biodiversity has decreased by 40
two percent specialists who drew up the
report say this is one of the reasons
for the decline in our wildlife the time
to act is now government needs to put
funding towards these projects towards
our conservation in our natural world
and it needs to sit up and say we've
lost enough we've got to stop the
decline and we've got to do something to
address all these drivers have changed
that are affecting our species in
response the government say they're
taking action now to make real changes
to reverse biodiversity loss through a
range of measures but as one species
here is being reintroduced another one
will be in decline this report makes it
clear that our state of nature needs an
urgent response in some rasheed sky news